alors que les vacances de noël
approchent à grands pas focus ce soir
sur à l'instruction à domicile en france
entre 60000 les soixante deux mille
enfants fera l'école à la maison
cela représente moins de 1 % de
l'effectif total des élèves une pratique
et qui pourrait être plus encadrés dès
la rentrée prochaine avec des demandes
d'autorisation auprès du rectorat
une annonce gouvernementale qui n'a pas
été très bien accueilli par les parents
concernés rencontre avec stéphanie une
maman de saint-avertin qui fait
l'instruction à la maison à ses trois
enfants et qui n'y voit que des
avantages
romain delville cet après midi ses
activités manuelles pour stéphanie la
maman instructrice et ses trois filles
de 10 6 et 4 ans je suis en train de
faire main de fer seulement jeu
principal et qui savent et qui a pour le
long de à toi qui joues c'est vrai la
mère de famille a commencé l'instruction
à la maison quand sa fille aînée avec
quatre ans chaque année elles ont fait
la demande à l'inspection académique
son credo c'est de partir du
questionnement des enfants pour partager
des savoirs
après pour le scolaire moi je pars du
principe qu'on l'a tous ces cerveaux
pris nos cerveaux c'était à notre mort
et que à partir du moment où j'essaye de
faire frétiller mais nous relancer je
comprendre les choses et la vérité c'est
que tout seul ils y arrivent très bien
tout seuls ils y arrivent très bien donc
je sais pas je n'ai aucune espèce
d'inquiétude par rapport aux capacités
intellectuelles morales physiques des
enfants pour moi ils sont pleinement
comment dire capables d'assumer ce
qu'ils ont envie d'entreprendre
nous notre seul rôle c'est d'être guide
quant à la question de l' isolement de
ses enfants du reste de la société
stéphanie balaie l'idée puisque ses
filles participent à des activités hors
temps scolaire nos enfants sont très
très ouvert et se font des amis aussi
bien avec des enfants qui sont à
l'instruction en famille avec des
enfants qui eux sont scolarisés par
exemple le mercredi elle est vraiment à
l'athlétisme j'ai dû scolaire c'est du
scolaire et on y voit différents
si les enfants ne pose pas la question
mais dans quelle école battus ils savent
pas cette mère de famille l'attestent si
ces enfants souhaitent aller dans une
école ou au collège est iront les elle
ne veut pas que ce soit la loi qui
l'imposent